دبلوماسيه متقلبه ولهجه اوروبيه متغيره
بتغير الظروف هذا ما بدت عليه تصريحات
جوزيف بوريل بين اليوم وامس لغه غير
الدبلوماسيه خطب بها بوريل كل الدول غير
الاوروبيه في اطار ملف الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا خاصه دول جنوب الكره الارضيه
ماذا يعني ولكن نعم ولكن لا نقبل نعم ولكن
هناك غزو
تصريحات غير مفاجئه فقد سبقها تشبيه اثار
غضب العالم فاوروبا حديقه مقارنه ببقيه
دول العالم التي وصفها بالادغال ضد
الدراجه
[موسيقى]
ليس حديقه بل معظمه ادغال ويمكن للادغال
ان تغزو الحديقه
يجب على اوروبا ان تتخلى عن عقليه ان
مشاكلها هي مشاكل العالم اما مشاكل العالم
ليست مشاكل اوروبا
اما باتجاه الشرق فقد خفت حده النبره ليصف
بوريد الصين التي لا تختلف مواقفها كثيرا
عن دول الجنوب يصفها بالقوه العظمى
والسؤال المطروح هو كيف ستستخدم قوتها في
حرب روسيا واوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
والعديد من قاده اوروبا وصف الصين كاكثر
شريك تجاريا في عده محافل فاشتراكه
الصينيه الاوروبيه باتت اليوم تنمو بشكل
اكبر من ذي قبل بل وحتى على حساب الشراكه
الاوروبيه الامريكيه
اذا عمر العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات